[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola que tal estais
cómo estáis
lo pregunto de verdad cómo estáis por
ejemplo tú cómo estás
estás bien qué bien que estés bien
aunque imagino que si no estuvieses bien
no me lo ibas a contar aquí delante de
todos primero porque la que ha venido a
hablar aquí soy yo y por qué no me
conoces de nada pero antes de empezar a
hablar yo me gustaría que os visualizase
en la última conversación que hayáis
tenido con alguien de confianza y que
habéis respondido ante esta pregunta de
cómo estás habéis sido sinceros con
nosotros mismos y con ellos
me gustaría que las madres que
estuviesen aquí levanten la mano
cuántas veces habéis compartido lo
maravilloso que es ser madre
muchas verdad
pero cuántas veces habéis confesado la
faena que es el parto los puntos las
grietas de los pezones
incluso los crueles que somos en muchas
ocasiones los hijos pero cómo vas a ser
tú la mala madre que compartas que la
maternidad en muchas ocasiones es una
gran putada
soy rocío alguien como vosotros alguien
como tú o como tú bueno como las que
habéis levanta antes la mano porque no
soy madre y tampoco os voy a hablar de
la maternidad soy rocío tengo 30 años
y llevo siete años trabajando en la
industria farmacéutica y qué hago en la
industria farmacéutica
pues me pasó los días de hospital en
hospital viendo médicos y actualizando
les sobre un tratamiento para un tipo de
cáncer es decir para hacerlo más fácil
aporto mi granito de arena para que cada
paciente
pueda disfrutar de un amanecer más
y la palabra tabú la palabra cáncer
antes fue un tabú hace muchos años pero
ahora no ahora cada vez más está en
nuestro vocabulario cada vez más
para bien y para mal para bien porque
sabemos más de ella y porque tenemos
muchos más tratamientos y cada vez
sabemos más pero también está más
presente porque cada vez conocemos más y
más casos que nos llegan de cerca y que
les ha tocado de una forma o de otra
pero lo que yo nunca me imaginaba es que
me iba a tocar a mí de cerca en casa y
con los míos
nunca jamás lo imaginé y es que en 2017
diagnosticaron a mi madre de un cáncer
con metástasis hepática no sé si muchos
de los que estáis aquí conocéis el
significado de la palabra metástasis
pero yo ya llevaba un tiempo en el
mundillo y sabía que la palabra
metástasis no pintaba nada bien
y que las probabilidades de que mi madre
se curase eran prácticamente nulas
y ya que os he hablado de su diagnóstico
y de que hace cuatro años se convirtió
no sólo mi madre sino también en mi
paciente y en protagonista de esta
historia me gustaría poder presentaros
la me gustaría aprovechar para
presentarlos la
es mi madre ya mi otro lado tenéis a mi
padre
él también se convirtió en mi paciente
y qué cosas tiene la vida o el destino
que tan sólo dos años después de que
diagnosticaron a mi madre
mi padre fue diagnosticado de un cáncer
de pulmón
y os he dicho antes que la palabra
metástasis
decía que tenía unas probabilidades
prácticamente nulas de curación y esto
es como cuando te hacen spoiler cuando
estás enganchado a una serie y te dicen
que lo que va a pasar pero no te lo
dicen claramente un spoiler un poco raro
sabíamos que iba a llegar pero no
sabíamos ni en qué temporada ni en qué
capítulo iv a mi padre
que está mi otro lado se enfrentaba
también a la temporada final de su vida
y qué cosas tiene la vida
perdona
[Aplausos]
y esta foto aún si cabe es mucho más
especial y mágica para mí porque
representa un momento único y es que
tengo muy pocas fotos con mis padres con
los dos juntos mis padres se divorciaron
cuando yo solo tenía un año
y allí no estábamos la enfermedad nos
había unido sentados en el mismo sofá y
es que recuerdo como si fuera ayer los
tres sentados tomando café y mi madre
compartía con mi padre que no se
preocupara que la quimio no era más que
un chute y que no lo pasaría tan mal
como decían y estábamos sonriendo porque
mi padre decía
que parecía en el dúo cómico del gordo y
el flaco mi madre hinchada por los
corticoides y mi padre en los huesos eso
sí mi padre decía que ninguno de los dos
tenía ni un pelo de tonto
y cuando yo pensaba y yo me decía para
mí bueno rocío piensa que las cosas poco
pueden ir peor tienes a los dos pilares
de tu vida con cáncer y
pensaba que nada podía ir peor puestas
en toda la frente nos encontrábamos en
medio de una pandemia mundial
haciendo malabares para cuadrar las
quimios de uno y del otro y parecía que
estudio estuviéramos escapando de la
policía saltando nos los confinamientos
perimetrales
mis padres ya no están
mi madre falleció en enero desde el año
y mi padre falleció en marzo también de
este año sólo pasaron 52 días desde la
muerte de uno a la muerte del otro y os
había dicho
nos habíamos ido preparando para ello
claro que nos habíamos ido preparando
para ello nos habían hecho ese spoiler
pero nunca estás preparado para que ese
momento llegue
pero a mí me gusta mucho pensar que la
serie continúa claro que continúa y es
que ellos en vez de protagonistas de
esta historia
quiero pensar que están detrás de las
cámaras uno está del guionista y otro
está de producción
y quizás
esto justifica un poco más la pasión con
la que cada día salgo a trabajar porque
cada vez que un médico me habla de un
paciente
pienso que podrían ser mis padres y
pienso en lo afortunados que son las
familias que pueden disfrutar de una
comida en familia un domingo de un
verano con amigos o de una noche
estrellada
pero no solo he venido a hablaros de
de mis padres y de a qué me dedico
porque podría estar horas y horas
hablando de las diferencias de actitud
ante la enfermedad entre uno y otro de
la aceptación
de la salud mental de los cuidadores
pero que tampoco he venido a hablar de
la resiliencia ni del poder del
mindfulness y de qué papel juega la
alimentación en ciertas enfermedades
he venido a hablar de la pregunta que os
hacía al principio de s cómo estáis de
verdad
porque yo estos años atrás muy pocas
veces he respondido a esta pregunta de
una forma real muy pocas veces he sido
sincera con quien me preguntaba muchas
veces se dice muy pocas veces he dicho
estoy hecho una y tengo miedo
tanta incertidumbre me está quemando por
dentro y ver a mis padres con tanta
toxicidad de los fármacos aún trabajando
en lo que trabajo me está matando
yo no fui sincera
pero es que mis padres tampoco lo fueron
a mí nunca me hablaron de su miedo a
morir e imagino que lo tendrían claro
que lo tendrían muy pocas veces he visto
a mis padres llorar y seguro que lo
hacían seguro que se escondían para no
hacerme entrañó a mí y yo me escondía
para no hacerle daño a ellos
y es que esto es algo así como si la
sociedad en general tuviéramos en mute o
en silencio las emociones desagradables
las cosas que nos pasan que nos hacen
estar regular o mal
y qué pasó pasó que tras la muerte de
mis padres
me negué a mí misma y me prometí que
nunca iba a contestar a la pregunta de
cómo estás de una forma irreal no iba a
fingir estar bien me iba a permitir
llorar como ha llorado con vosotros si
lo necesitaba hablarlo si quería
compartirlo tomé la decisión de desmote
ar y compartir porque esto forma parte
de mi serie de mi capítulo
y qué ha pasado
cuando me des mute cuando compartí como
os he contado a vosotros que en menos de
50 días me había quedado huérfano
porque porque no compartimos los
renglones de nuestra vida los renglones
torcidos de nuestra vida
pues me enfrente me enfrenté a sentirme
mal porque parecía que al contar mi
historia
parecía que yo me hacía la víctima de mi
historia y es que me enfrentado a
silencios incómodos
a que la gente me respondiera con un que
bien lo llevas y yo muchas veces en mi
cabeza decía pero como quieres que lo
lleve
o incluso recuerdo que sobre todo los
primeros meses mis amigas no me contaban
absolutamente nada y se habían discutido
con su novio ni si habían tenido un
problema en el trabajo
o simplemente si estaban hechas polvo
porque tenían la regla
y es que me decían rocío pero como te
vamos a contar a ti
nuestros problemas porque al lado de lo
tuyo lo nuestro es una tontería y yo les
decía de tonterías nada es que a cada
uno nos pesa nuestra mochila
independientemente de la mochila del de
al lado
porque porque no lo compartimos
pues
probablemente por una carencia de la
gestión emocional que tenemos en nuestra
sociedad porque nadie nos enseña a
gestionar a aceptar a escuchar ya
expresar nuestras emociones nadie nos
enseña desde que somos pequeños y si
nadie nos enseña a hacerlo con las
nuestras imaginaros lo difícil que es
escuchar aceptar o gestionarlas de
alguien que te lo cuenta
y es que recientemente en diciembre de
2020 la unesco compartió un informe que
se titula
la gestión emocional en la educación en
tiempos de pandemia os invito a que lo
leáis es una reflexión de la importancia
que tiene tras esta crisis sanitaria que
hemos vivido
tanto tiempo encerrados tantos miedos
tantas pérdidas frustraciones nos hemos
quedado muchas gentes sin trabajo
os invito a que leáis el informe que
habla de la importancia
de incluir las competencias socio
emocionales en nuestros currículums
vitae
porque así tendremos un según un futuro
mucho más exitoso
y es que esto de los mba que tan de moda
está de las escuelas prestigiosas está
fenomenal
pero para mí hay un máster que es mucho
más interesante un máster que me ha
inventado que yo he llamado máster de
estar emocionalmente vivos
mv pero como esto de el español ya
sabéis que vende poco y lo que está de
moda son las siglas y los acrónimos en
inglés lo he llamado en bi y eim
es un máster en being emotional y alive
es un máster y real colaborativo del que
todos tendríamos que formar parte del
que todos tendríamos que asistir desde
que somos pequeños
y es un máster en el que no existe un
programa educativo en el que vamos
aprendiendo a lo largo de nuestro camino
de nuestras experiencias vitales y que
nos va conformando quiénes somos
y las prácticas de cada uno son las de
cada uno y no hay unas prácticas ni
mejores ni peores las prácticas del
compañero de al lado nada tienen que ver
con las tuyas es verdad que a mí las
prácticas que me han tocado son un poco
cabronas y quizás bueno me tocó un poco
joven pero cada uno tenemos las nuestras
y lo importante es aceptarlas lo
importante es que podamos si necesitamos
compartir con nuestro compañero de vida
esas prácticas que nos ha tocado vivir
que hablemos de ello
y ahora vuelvo a dirigirme a las madres
pero también me gustaría dirigirme a
todos vosotros a todos los que me estáis
escuchando me gustaría que os sintáis
parte de este másters de estar
emocionalmente vivos me gustaría
que os permitáis
aceptar las emociones todas tal y como
vienen porque nacemos con ellas de serie
no las cap hemos no las autos en sur
hemos permitirnos y aceptamos también
las de nuestros amigos las de nuestros
familiares las de los compañeros de
trabajo
me gustaría que hoy os llevéis esta
pregunta y tú cómo estás
gracias
[Aplausos]